hi there day 25 I'm keeping this up I'm
gonna keep going until day and day 90
today was a productive day insofar as
language learning is concerned I put in
about an hour and a half to two hours of
linking and some new lessons that have
been put into our link library Korean
one is they're both from Radio Free Asia
it seems like a lot of sort of somewhat
propaganda propaganda type materials
what's generally available without any
conditions attached so you know Voice of
Russia Voice of America Radio Free
chosen Radio Free Asia these kinds of
things are typically available without
any strings attached they want to get
their message out but some of the
content is quite interesting so I spent
probably yeah close to two hours
creating a bunch of links so that now I
can read these at my leisure because all
of the unknown words will already have
been looked up they're yellow and I can
easily on i link on my ipad just point
at them and and read them more
comfortably than sitting in front of a
computer so that was a good two hours
then I went up skiing and I'm gonna show
you I started out my house it was cool
today it's close to zero Celsius which
is a couple of degrees three four
degrees colder than normal and it was a
clear day but it's green where I live
perfectly green and you'll see in fact I
shot up a picture just right by my house
and a video and it didn't turn out so
you the first little snippet won't show
but the second snippet is just at the
turnoff to the road up to Cypress Bowl
then there's a little snippet from the
lookout which is probably 15 minutes
from my house and then from there it's
another 10 minutes so 25 minutes from my
house I'm skiing and that's what you're
gonna see in this little sequence it
follows and then I'll come back again
with a few more comments about language
learning is now about seven minutes
later
the park the school near my house and
here is where the Cypress Bowl road is
so I'm just gonna get on this road and
head up the Cypress park now here we are
it's basically 15 minutes and set up my
house on my way up to Cypress and we can
see the City of Vancouver down below and
there's other people here at this
lookout and I'll get over here where I
get a better view of it and there you
can see the Lions Gate Bridge and the
downtown area Vancouver and off in the
distance we have Burnaby and other parts
of the city here we have ships in the
bay waiting to unload Joss there is the
university take a picture cypress tree
which is 1500 years old and three meters
in diameter
Piper's will because there are a lot of
cypress trees out there by the way no
basically 25 minutes from my home ten
minutes from the lookout here we are
there is very little snow this year very
unusual normally I get a pass for the
year this year I'm buying my tickets
each time I come and I come after three
o'clock because that way I save a bit of
money and I get the afternoon rate along
with my seniors rate so it doesn't cost
me very much think it's like 11 dollars
or something and I go for a couple of
hours which is really all I can manage
cuz I work up a really good sweat doing
it while listening to my language down
there somewhere is the water if you can
see it against the Sun and off to the
left side the trails I just came out of
and I'm gonna head back into and the
snow is hard and packed but it's white
and it's quite cold and sorry will
continue my skiing here you can see the
different trails and there's a skier
about the pass through in front of us
and there again it's a little darker a
little cooler in the trails and you know
there's also up here to the peak but
mostly it's just a lot of cars captive
trails here and that's where I'm headed
now as I say we have less snow than
normal the snow conditions actually are
very good it's like mid winter
conditions even though there isn't very
much of it they packed it down they
spread it out on the trails
there's also snowshoe trails here that's
a great paradise for the citizens of
Vancouver so here's the trail and I'm
gonna try and ski down this slope here
without crashing holding my poles in one
hand just to give you a sense of the
condition here and here we go we're
gonna head down here and if I end up in
a heat here you'll have it recorded for
you but I'm just gliding down here on my
cross-country skis and getting close to
quitting time and I thought I'd do a
little run like that here so you can see
that two hours of vigorous cross-country
skiing and it was clear and the snow was
clear and crisp under the skis and
breathing that mountain air in the
forest and stuff coming back home have a
nice hot bath nice dinner watch the
Canucks lose another hockey game and now
I'm ready to do a little reading on my
iPad you must think I'm crazy the amount
of time I put into learning Korean
normally I would norm I would just do an
hour a day but I'm committed to this 90
day challenge I want to do it one
comment you know I was skiing and I
didn't have my my boob properly I had I
have two types of cross-country skis the
classical style and then the skating
style which I've started out more
recently and I didn't have my boot in
properly and every time I tried to push
off kind of push on that leg it would be
slide and I finally I realized that I
had my boot on the wrong way so it made
me think you know everything you do you
can do it the right way in the wrong way
particularly in something like you know
putting your skis on the right way and
definitely issues of technique in things
like cross-country skiing but when it
comes to language learning I think
there's a we have a little more freedom
we can have our different ways I noticed
that at the 90 day challenge statistics
at Linc I'm right near the top which I
don't like I like it when there's people
working harder than me but I'm one of
the more active ones one of the reasons
that I get high scores on my activity
index is that I create a lot of links
and
in Korean the way our system works is
you immediately get us suggested you
know if you look up a word and unknown
word you get a suggested meaning from
Google Translate which in the case of
Korean is often wrong not very helpful
in Czech it's very good I found it very
reliable then we have these user hints
which are words that some of our members
have already gone to look up in a
dictionary and they come up right away
and then if none of those are look like
they make sense then you look it up in a
dictionary I tend to normally when I'm
doing Czech or other languages I just go
with a user hint or I go with a Google
Translate and it's good enough and later
on if I want to refine that hint I
refine it in Korean I tend to go to the
dictionary more often because I'm often
very curious to see if there is a
Chinese character attached to it and if
there is then I will bring it in and
make that part of the hint as we call it
the definition there was a lively
discussion that darling forum today
there are a lot of people who put a lot
more effort into each hint they look it
up they want to make sure that they've
got the conjugation and all kinds of
additional information and so forth
which is fine and so there I don't think
there is a wrong or a right way if when
it comes to language learning as I
mentioned yesterday Luka has his
translation thing that he does and the
thing about long journey is it's such a
personal thing if you had to do it some
way that other people think is good but
you don't like doing that I think would
be discouraging the fun thing about
language learning is you can find things
that interest you you can do things that
interest you you can bend it around to
suit your interests and whatever you can
do to make it you know fun and
interesting and worthwhile for you is
gonna keep you at the task and if you
stay at the task you're gonna improve so
I was thinking about that as I was
charging around you know that that
certain things require you know you have
to do it this way like judo you know you
have this cut that you've got to do it
this way but in language learning I feel
we have to explore and find the ways
that we find the most enjoyable and
effective and so to that extent it's a
it's a very it's very much an in
vidual journey and so but today I'm
gonna be over four hours today so I hope
some of you out there who are taking the
challenge are gonna compete with me in
terms of you know activity level weather
on the link activity index or in terms
of the number of hours you put in
because the more you put in the more
you're gonna get out bye for now